hello or glad you've joined us for this
live webinar flexible manufacturing
strategies for cell and gene therapy
products I am Judy Oracle laberd's and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by to room Obi CT -
room Obi CT a global leader in blood
component therapeutic a phoresis and
cellular technologies believes in the
potential of blood and cells to do even
more for patients than they do today
- room obesity's cell therapy
technologies business enables
researchers developers and manufacturers
to create next-generation cell and gene
therapies to learn more visit w-w-w comm
slash machine efficiency let's get
started you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your screen
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker when Yong Yong
from Tomo BCT when Yong Yong PhD is the
regional expert for the cell therapy
technologies portfolio of teramo BCT
responsible for managing knowledge
transfer and implementation of efficient
and safe manufacturing
Solutions in the biotechnology and cell
therapy field dr. Liang works closely
with various industry representatives
researchers and clinicians throughout
Asia Pacific she's very passionate about
the advances in cell and gene based
therapy and seeks active dialogue with
stakeholders in the field on bringing
innovations to the patient prior to
joining the cell processing team of
teramo BCT she spent four productive
years in academic research on cell based
regenerative medicine platforms working
on a variety of cell types and
biomaterials her contribution of ten
research articles and three patents to
this specialty resulted in a PhD in
bioengineering confirm n't from Nanyang
Technological University Singapore when
young will now begin her presentation
thank you hello everyone today I will be
speaking about flexible manufacturing
strategies for cell and gene therapy
products I want to start by highlighting
the concept of automation and then I
will move on to showcasing the
flexibility of quantum scale extension
system through five different
applications and its case study let's
begin
throughout the industry there is a
consensus that automation for advanced
therapy product manufacturing is
critical for business success the visit
now is when should we incorporate
automation we have to recognize the
distinction priorities along the
development cycle of the therapeutic
product scientists are focused on
figuring up the process innovation
product profile and proving that therapy
works on the other end of the spectrum a
manufacturing mindset is direct success
meeting quality requirements having a
scalable and reproducible manufacturing
process while managing the cost of goods
in order to be accessible as a treatment
option
when is the right time to automate the
common excuses to delay automation are
the cost of investing amidst grappling
with the uncertainty and complex nature
of process development
unfortunately when you are finally ready
to change the manufacturing strategy to
be commercially viable
it is either too late so much more
difficult to change test the process and
reagents will define the product and
will be detailed in your IND submission
the reality is the process and cost of
goods are locked in here any change
there Arthur will require some form of
comparability studies including
repeating very costly clinical trials
and in these very competitive industry
and increased planning to markets can
have devastating consequences
trolling from experience and case
studies we strongly believe that one has
to begin with the end in mind gain
clarity on what is important at
commercial production and work backwards
to implement strategies that will enable
your business viability to manage cost
these are some major areas for your
consideration firstly select three
agents that can meet manufacturing
policy and regulatory requirements as
well as defining and optimize your
process to reduce the volume of reagents
consumed
second optimize the processing steps
which come from the deep understanding
of yourself click away any steps and
tests that are not necessary
first find ways to reduce the need for
high-end facility space reach at on a
fixed significant cost independent of
your productivity you can do this by
utilizing small footprint devices and
choosing closed systems that can be used
in lower grade clean room facility
for automation of the most
labor-intensive tasks can help to reduce
number of staff and the level of skill
required this also helps to reduce
operator related errors and variability
number five reduce the time and labor
required for long SOPs and expensive
manual documentation by adopting
automation and it's electronic records
and lastly we get to a minimum meet for
process change and therefore the need
for revalidation moving from one bio
rector to a larger one is considered a
process change compared to scaling out
the concepts of expansion system is
designed for manufacturing without
compromising flexibility if this is a
GMP in a box replacing the incubator
biosafety cabinets and cleanroom
typically required for Glasgow based
culture users all around the world that
use this bench top device for very cell
culture explication and academic and
commercial stressing briefly the
features are listed below
by doing a closed system with single-use
disposable it reduces the risk of
contamination and therefore reduces the
need for higher grade clean room
facility
Automation greatly simplifies the most
error-prone and labor-intensive steps of
the cell culture percent the electronic
documentation feature also enables
traceability
increase reproducibility by removing
operator to operator variation and
therefore better variability
and lastly the quantum allows a fully
scalable and flexible manufacturing
approach increased demand can be
immediately met with additional quantum
systems without lengthy process
development and revalidation associated
with skill up systems
quantum it's a benchtop profusion based
bio record system that can cultured both
appearance and suspension cells you can
think of the director as a Pringles can
containing 11,500 semi permeable hollow
fibers let's give it to point 1 square
meters of surface area this is
equivalent to 120 t125 flash
the semi permeable membrane of the
hollow fibers equipped the by Ritzer
with two separate environments
intra capillary I see and read pictures
within big hollow fibers and BC extra
capillary which is the space outside the
hollow fibers this is denoted in boots
the hollow fiber membrane has an
approximate molecular weight cut off
that is 17 kilo Dalton the icy and easy
environment attend separated and allow
us to have two different fluid sources
in the direction
we can keep cells and large molecules
such as serum proteins and cytokines in
one environment
while small molecules such as glucose
and lactate can freely move between the
two environments
this design helps to greatly reduce
cytokine usage and therefore cost but
many think the cytokines empty I see
look with the cells and exchange in
glucose and metabolic waste using basil
needle on the EC side we will stick
later about this advantage if you can
see the graph on the lower right hand
corner confirming in our left very
little interleukin 2 passed through from
the IC type depicted in red to the EC
site in boom through up ascend a t-cell
culture person
in protest I'm going to monitor the cell
growth is easily managed through
assembling port as we move to
manufacturing large batches we should
not depend on qualitative operator
dependent judgment of confluence as a
gauge of cell growth or harvesting which
leads to process variability daily set
fault of lactate can provide a
quantitative measure of how well the
cells are growing and can help the
operator decide whether to increase the
feed rate to maintain the nutrients and
waste balance and to predict the pitch
of the cell proliferation cycle and
determine if it is time to happen
and finally to predict the expected cell
numbers in the quantum the graph below
shows correlation between selected
generation rates with the actual number
of T cells harvested from the bio resin
here I will be presenting five case
studies published by quantum users in
peer-reviewed journals as you can see
the quantum is very flexible and
suitable for various applications from
cell expansion to viral vector
production
for this application let's discuss
adherence expansion in the form of
mesenchymal stem cells dr. Patrick
Henley from Baylor College of Medicine
published a paper on MSC expansion
directly from whole bone marrow in two
consecutive passages to briefly explain
the affirmance of the slides from here
onwards you will see a green box
timeline bar and the main touch points
in it they note that s dot the details
of the main step are in the gray boxes
below
now you will see in this you will see in
this quantum run there are four main
steps for a primary culture of MSE
the first step will have the director
prepared and coated with an adherence
promoter such as fibronectin
the next a 25 and else of bone marrow
experts were loaded into the quantum and
cells are allowed to attach on the
hollow fibers for 48 hours
then the quantum will perform an
automatic washout of non adhered cell
and continue feeding the adhered cells
for another 11 day
dr. Hanley has the flexibility to use D
and E em with five percent human
platelet lysate and cultures itself
under hypoxic condition daily glucose
that successful allow him to adjust the
fifth rate to match the cell growth and
finally determine that the cells were
ready for harvest at day 14
at this last step 180 ml of triple
Celeste was hooked on to the system the
course of autumn it's the harvest
protocol and 15 million MSC for
harvested in 13 minutes
the passage one Embassy's written
subculture to obtain clinically relevant
numbers new disposable was fitted onto
the quantum system and coated with
fibronectin for four hours before 20
million cells were loaded after a
24-hour attachment place the bio rector
was profusion set for the next five to
six days
Desalle expansion was monitored by the
daily glucose and Lexus and both as well
at the end of the week 616 million cells
were harvested in a small 400 ml volume
on average
dr. family found a significant impact
from switching from manual flask to the
quantum system firstly
Cole was highly simplified into four
automated main steps for each passage
direct loading of bone marrow without
cycle separation was also possible with
the quantum system
secondly time and labor savings were
achieved through automation you can look
at the graph the table on the right hand
side the quantum chip 21 days and two
passages to produce 200 million cells
compared to 30 days and four passages in
the manual flat culture further harvest
being most time sensitive requires five
stuff and six hours in the manual
process which was highly automated and
quick in the quantum otherwise
third the amount of disposables and
reagents were also greatly reduced not
ugly and abling cost savings but also
simplifying supply chain and logistics
and finally a small harvest volume of
quantum a lot easier downstream
processing and therefore two staff
members were able to complete the
harvest and downstream processing within
45 minutes as compared to 39 hours in
the manual person
next I would like to showcase our
in-house laboratory protocol on
expanding T cells in this 2018 paper we
reposted a simple standard protocols
expense 100 million peripheral blood
mononuclear cells PBMCs to yield 26 to
30 billion T cell briefly we have
collected ourselves on the spectra of
care and then we have isolated bit cells
using the term obesity's in nutria of
five homes
this allowed freezing of the cells
without passports viability issues
100 million PBMC on average were thought
and mixed with CD 3 CDs 28 dynabeads
in a one-to-one ratio for activation and
then load it on to the quantum system
two different media compositions were
you
Joseph set on the icy site with tex-mex
supplements which il-2 cytokine
while metabolic exchange was performed
primarily through the EC size using
basil medium inter last step at day 10
28 billion cells were harvested on
average within four minutes into a one
litter cover today
our scientists have developed a very
simple protocol to expand t-cells in the
quantum system firstly no pre culture
was required to make a minimum seeding
number in thought cells were directly
loaded and expended in the quantum in a
correct table you can see the quantum
produced a highly pure city 3 positive T
cell population with very no pd-1
exhaustion marker expression
second in a small bench top device with
190 ml of hollow fiber volume we were
able to pack 30 billion cells because of
the excellent gas exchange our design
can provide
we were also able to harvest base 30
billion cells quickly and in a small
volume of 700 ml from average so one
Operator was able to handle the
downstream processing and finally they
do on loop I see in CD dine provided
significant savings in cytokine use by
using basil media on the easy side to
exchange glucose and lactate and keeping
the pressure kind with itself on the
artsy side we were able to reduce the
use of il-2 by 80% and serum by 90%
our first case study is from City of
Hope
this recent publication reported the
expansion and adenoviral transduction of
Newark stem cells and SC in five quantum
systems which were then pulled for
clinical cell Bank for clinical trial
here if first we prepare and coat the
bioreactor overnight the first step and
then loaded 52 million NSC
the cells were then expended to
confluence for its day and adenoviral
vector was added at day nine
the incubation and feeding can be
performed automatically
I know day
a picture of 1.6 billion and s seeds for
harvested from each quantum food and
cryopreserved I also like to mention at
this point that they have since
completed a phase 1 trial using
allergenic neural stem cells pull from 7
quantum systems
you
because of the limited space in their
existing facility if your hope would
have had to perform multiple batches to
achieve the target of eight billion
cells
with the quantum they could do more with
the current resources and produce its
billion cells in one single batch
therefore reducing the time in GMP
production Street by 60% and eliminating
costs from multiple locks release
testing you can choose it in BigTable
they also found a ten times lower
ceiling density was possible on quantum
therefore reducing the amount of
preparation for the starting product
firstly the small footprint of the
quantum system meant they could fit
several units in their current facility
increasing their manufacturing output to
its clinical production skill and
finally whether it was one high or
seventh Quantum's City of Hope
demonstrated the scalability and
reproducibility of the device in
producing cells that with really 16
criteria
we have Malcolm too
our final application sells the crystal
production because of the dual look the
design of our director we are able to
program the device to a production skin
of your choice
that's why are continuously on the Left
we can collect in batches by closing the
icy loop to concentrate the secretive
product MBE I see look while exchanging
nutrients and removing waste through the
easy look after a set time interval
it can flash the ante look quickly to
push up the secret oh and obtain a small
volume that highly concentrated product
in a bed
is so desire we can also adopt
continuous production on the right where
we can continuously seek the icy look
and push up the product through the IP
address this results in high volume and
low concentration products
in the next two slides I will share with
you how to of our customers fab utilized
each of these skins successfully
dr. rassul calories group in MD Anderson
reports at the successful X's on
production with the quantum using that
collection skin every two days for
period of to update
in that protocol the question was to use
two expense NFC mesenchymal stem cell
for 90 days with serum supplements with
media until confluence was reached
the media was automatically replaced
with serum free media for Isis on
production
to set ER DET site called the icy site
must kept very quiet and closed to allow
the build-up of X's on at the end of 48
hours 150 ml of product was pushed out
of the icy look into a bed this was
repeated another five times in the next
ten days
in another instance doctor your heart
our from UC Davis use a continuous
collection scheme to produce let the
viral vectors from text 293 t-cells
after a organized fiber next encoding
preset text to 930 cells were loaded
onto the console and allows the extent
before transaction as we know
transaction is very time-sensitive and
labor-intensive here the quantum
automates the transaction stack of
incubating and washing up the toxic mix
without operator intervention
post transaction the media was stretched
to a serum free media automatically and
viral vectors were collected
continuously in the Westerbeck over the
next 40 hours and finally the hex to
nitrous t-cells will automatically
convert it for QC
taken together the quantum demonstrate
high flexibility to suit our customers
goal and simplifying previously
laborious manual tasks into a few highly
automated steps
unlike other viruses the quantum can be
configured to yield a small volume
concentrated product that can be easily
handled at downstream processing finally
our customers and their regulatory
authorities appreciate the closed nature
of the quantum in producing viral
vectors
you
previously I mentioned that most of the
processes locked at IMD submission for
clinical trials and cell therapy
developers should begin their process
development with manufacturing concepts
in line while cost financial and process
uncertainty can seem to be common
barriers to automation it does not have
to be solved with direct solution you
can automate early without compromising
flexibility
the various case studies presented today
have collected three demonstrative
quantum flexibility in culturing various
cell types and applications as well as
throughout our customers process
development cycle our users have also
been able to transition into clinical
use with the quantum indeed the has been
more than eleven IND submissions
worldwide incorporating quantum in their
process and several clinical trials in
process or completed at this point
finally the examples illustrate how
automation can bring immediate return
including production efficiency
reduction of specialized labor reagent
savings and real estate savings in both
academic and commercial setting
with this I thank you for your attention
and we'll be happy to take any questions
thank you
you
thank you in yen for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window we
will ask a question and click on the
send button when Yan will answer as many
questions as time permits the first
question is what are the cleanroom
requirements for quantum
thank you Judy
the functionally closed nature of the
quantum system provides the flexibility
for the environment in which the quantum
system can be run so the case study that
we have published a couple years ago
demonstrated the ability to produce
cells missing all safety requirements
for example sterility endotoxins and
mycoplasma while operating in an
unclassified space but ultimately
cleanroom requirements for all clinical
production are at a purview of local
regulatory authorities
thank you the next one is is the quantum
system GMP compliant
the quantum system ate the GMP
compliance by being a functionally
closed and automated system in addition
they software within the quantum system
is compatible with CFR 21 part 11
requirements so we have run reports that
are locked automatically use their
authentication and automatic recording
of temperature and pressure throughout
the run
thank you your next one is how do you
get the cells out of the quantum system
so cells are removed in a manner that is
consistent with a flask based process
the quantum system for to make a system
wash to remove this the media and
replace it with a wash solution and then
it adds the cell release reagent of your
choice incubate it for a couple of
minutes according to your protocol and
then the cell suspension is then
collected into a pre connected harvest
back in four minutes or less so under
they know merge the consensus our users
have been able to use the same release
agent that they are currently using in
the flask based process thank you the
next one is is there shear stress on the
cells in the quantum
so we have a paper on that that was
published about five years ago
it's called genetic stability of the MSE
is that are cultured from the quantum
system itself in psychotherapy Journal
so although some quantum tasks for
example at the blush are using very high
flow rates they are not representative
of the flow rate inside of bio rectus
five words because we have eleven
thousand fibers in the quantum
bioreactor the fluid flow is broken up
into this fibrous and in our study it's
reported negligible shear even during
the harshest flow conditions when
compared to manual piping
in addition many of our customers are
brought the world has evaluated the
quantum system and analyzed SLE quality
they have found them to be of similar
acceptable quality as compared to their
current processes so for example in City
of Hope which we just mentioned
previously they had a batch of cells
that will quote from seven quantum
systems and the ultimate release Christ
religious testing criteria and we'll
compare about the flux this cells are
then used in a phase one trial
thank you the next one is have you
compared the quantum and GES wave cell
expansion system for immune cell
expansion
some of our customers are currently
doing best whether we are doing that in
our laboratory I cannot disclose thank
you okay thank you next one is any
reference to use this quantum system in
cell therapy commercial production
you
for commercial production I wouldn't be
able to comment I'm not very sure about
that but I can say that there has been
11 more than 11 IMD submissions that
utilize the quantum as part of their
processes which has been approved
throughout the US and email in Europe
there has been at least three different
clinical trials that are currently
ongoing or completed with cells that
were produced on the quantum
thank you next one is what is the
maximum volume that quantum can produce
per machine
you
so I'm trying to understand the question
in terms of maximum volume if we're
talking about cell numbers it really
depends on the cells that are the list
of questions so I can't really answer
this but perhaps I can give you a
ballpark in terms of cell numbers for
MSC we have customers who have cultured
up to 1 billion cells 1 billion MSC and
for neuro stem cells as City of Hope has
published they have consistently
harvested about 1.6 billion neuro stem
cells per quantum and for the suspension
cells in our lab we have gone on to
optimize the self protocol for culturing
t-cells and we have been getting upwards
of 40 billion cells per run
thank you so we'll wait just a few
moments for any other questions that
might be coming in seems people are
sending in their questions they're
thinking about what they want to ask you
and they're taking their time to ask you
some questions so wait just a moment we
welcome more questions of course
and you know what I can we can move
along and then if people do have
questions that come in as we're talking
here at the end we can just ask them we
can just jump back and ask those
questions so I would like to once again
thank one-yen for her presentation do
you have any final comments
you
thank you Judy at this point I would
like to thank all our participants and
if you have any more questions please
reach out to us thank you great thanks
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions any questions we
did not get to today will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank our
sponsor to room o BCT for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through July 15
2019 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye